on linkedin live and i will welcome
everyone on webex and
youtube
live
give me just a moment
linkedin live and i will welcome
everyone on webex and
youtube welcome to our live live
audience as well give me just a moment
and
my name is stuart creek i am a
manager here at simply learn
introduce our program today
which is a digital marketing master
class in our learn it live series
with bernadette chamber the founder of
the socialite hive
top trainer in digital marketing and she
will be talking to you about
creating customer personas for effective
marketing campaigns taking us through
some examples
for people who are on webex you can
interact with our panel with the
via the q and a box fx
you can chat to all panelists um
possibly asking a couple questions along
the way bernadette may ask you for
an answer too but i will also be asking
some poll questions and we're going to
start with one of those in a minute
people watching on our streaming
services
feel free to put your questions into the
chat
pass those along to
so let's start with a poll question for
our webex audience
and this one is pretty straightforward
how much work experience do you have
not necessarily in digital marketing but
how much work experience do you have
out in the real world and we also do a
checking question how are you feeling
today are you doing today
um
been asking that since march of 2020
for obvious reasons with surges and
lockdowns and things like that coming
and going
check in to make sure everybody's
doing okay
so i'll give you another five seconds to
answer the poll
and
then i'll show you the result
and bernadette we have uh
an interesting uh audience today because
we have about uh
50 of them who are either still in
university or
you in the workforce but we have about a
quarter of our audience who are
uh seasoned veterans with more than 10
years of experience
the other good thing is that um
nearly everybody is saying they're
feeling pretty good or at least okay
today
we hope that what you have to share will
help improve the outlook of the rest
so
i'm going to introduce you
and in fact i'll let you describe
yourself a little in more detail before
i
stop sharing this and let you
share your screen so
um bernie why don't you go speak about
yourself here
absolutely so welcome everyone thanks
for joining us on our digital marketing
learn it live
um i don't really spend a whole lot of
time talking about myself but just in
short i have been in digital marketing
since 2012 have seen digital marketing
evolve over the years and there's a lot
of different things for visibility that
we learn that we grow from and that we
understand about the process so i have
been with simply learn
almost five going on six years now so
i'm really excited about that um and
i've been teaching a combination of both
digital marketing and digital
transformation and what we're
specifically going to focus on today is
how i walk my students on creating
customer personas and understanding the
customer journey so that they are able
to craft marketing campaigns
now
with that said how many of you are
familiar with the customer journey go
ahead and type that in the chat
familiar with the customer journey
all right so it seems like quite a bit
if you're familiar with the customer
journey and that you uh and you know
about it so we're going to be speaking
specifically to that and really diving
in on some of those areas now i don't
see
the share button highlighted steward if
you could um
you could go ahead and enable that
process and i'll get started there you
are
perfect
it's still showing uh grayed out on my
end
you should have access but let me fix
that again i'll try one more time here
oh good
if i need to duck out and come back in i
can
there you are
okay
deal i tell you what i'm going to do um
let me try ducking out and ducking in
again but i'll only mute stop video and
share i think it might be because we
were
on a session before so i'm going to duck
out and come back in all right all right
and
please bear with us for a moment well
bernadette
rejoins the session
and
and she'll be able to
share her screen um
i'm gonna send a chat message about the
audio
all right
okay
hi
bernadette can you hear me
i can i can't oh you're muted i'm on you
i needed you
i'm trying to unmute you
can you check your audio setting please
technical difficulties please stand by
okay
huh
are you able to go into the webex audio
settings bernadette on
next to the mute button there
apologize uh to everyone for the
difficulties here
something that
occasionally happens with the webex
system
so
please be patient we will have her back
on in just a moment
and here she comes
not connected to audio
i'm going to send you a
a new link
bernadette and if you try that maybe
i'll bring you be able to bring you in
from the
attendee side
give me a moment here
and i'm going to ping it to you in the
chat privately
so copy this link
and see if you can come in that
way and again i'm letting everyone know
here that um
we're having a webex difficulty getting
bernadette connected
back into the audio and sharing system
so
again please be patient
where is everybody from by the way if
you put in the chat
your
city and country
like to get a feel for
kuwait bye
nepal
lagos nigeria
mon jordan
from syria
sri lanka
of course many many people from india
all over
cape town south africa punta cana and
the dominican republic
germany
we have in charlotte
north carolina in the us
cameroon in africa
pakistan
greece
this is wonderful we have people from
just so many different countries and
parts of the world
so i am hoping i will be able to get
uh
simply
there
so
one moment
here
and we're still waiting for bernadette
to rejoin so
okay
here she comes
all right how about now
i hear you now
okay excellent
i had to i went to a different device
just in case it was
id10t so
yeah
now uh it's still showing that this
share screen is greyed so if we could
i just gave that privilege to you is it
is it coming through
um
i don't see it on my end it's still
showing out grade
i don't know if that is
i don't know
am i in my share
my share feature or share access is
grayed out
huh
let me
do this one more time
if you have slides you can send to me i
can present them from this side but um
um
i don't have slides they're live
demonstrations but what we can do is
if you go into
um
there's three specific websites i don't
know if my chats were coming through to
you
um but i will oh yes okay perfect so
there's three different type ch chats
the first chat is going to be www dot
um
ask
or answer the public
okay
dot com
and then there's going to be
www.sparkturo.com
and then
there is going to be a customer journey
um there's a customer journey
document
you're sending these on the chat to me
right now yeah i just sent them i sent
it to presenter
do you have to make it oh no no send it
send it to um host
okay host
all right so www dot answer the public
i'm a panelist so that might be an issue
too i'm out i entered in as a panelist
so that's that's that's supposed to work
perfectly well
okay
i apologize to you and to the audience
for
this difficulty
okay i've got the answer the public i've
got spark toro
all right so third one
all right and then if you would do me a
quick favor and google
customer journey and there is going to
be a
purple
graphic that populates first so if you
google customer journey okay
that will be what populates first
it'll say retail customer journey
okay i've got
let me see if i can put in retail
the right answer
oh you just needed to do customer
journey you didn't have to go to retail
uh i might be getting the
slight oh here we go purple graphic uh
set of arrows
yep that's it
okay
so
give me a moment and i will share my
screen
all right perfect thank you
all right
and i should be
so shall we start with the graphic or do
you want to start with we're going to
start with the graphic
[Music]
okay
second
all right
it's not working on that end either
uh are you seeing my screen
i don't see anything
you don't
i see an interesting thing
what's going on here
is that coming through are you seeing my
screen now
i see nothing
the audience says that they see it i
can't see anything
that
is
bizarre
i only see your camera i don't see
anything else
okay we have the graphic on the screen
and we have the graphic that starts with
it was difficult to compare options on
my phone
a retail customer journey
okay
um so i guess i have to do this blind
i have no idea why we're having these
issues we never have these issues um
so
the only thing that i see is you so
essentially guys um what this graphic
entails
is it talks about the different the
various areas of the customer journey
where it starts and where it ends and i
want you guys to think about exactly how
you actually go into purchases
how you
[Music]
think about your products the services
that you research and typically it
starts with a google research
starts with your need whatever that need
or problem is then it goes into a google
search and then after that you actually
go ahead and move down the purchase well
those various stages that you go through
is customer journey and there are
technology parameters and things like
that that powers the retail customer
journey it doesn't even have to be
retail actually it can be in services it
can be in products it can be in a number
of things right so the example that i
would like to use here is i would like
to use hellofresh so stuart there was a
website that i sent to you called
hellofresh if you could type in
www.hellofresh.com
and then just let me know whenever you
have it up
and then i'm going to be looking at it
on my end over here
just let me know whenever you have it
and then we'll go from there
yes it's up okay perfect so hello fresh
is a meal kit delivery service now a
person that would
want to
engage in a meal kit delivery service
may have several different questions or
several different touch points that
would initiate their journey to hello
fresh and so i bring up this website
because there's a specific offer here
you can decline the offer but i like to
use this in my in class examples because
it highlights several different things
you can actually
see reviews and see different
sentiments that a customer would have
now if you bring up answer the public
right next to that so you can go ahead
and type in answer the public for me
this will be considered as a meal kit so
in that little spot in that little box i
want you to type in meal
kit
service
and then hit search
now answer the public is a free tool
they only allow you a certain amount of
searches per day but it's absolutely
free you can use it at any time
and basically what it does is it shows
us all of the questions that a person
might type in to find a meal kit service
right
so you will see
the how the which the who the when will
what and are
so our meal kit service is worth it our
meal delivery service worth it read it
are they healthy
what service is the best
so all of these different areas show you
sort of the sentiment
that surrounds meal kit services
some folks here are health conscious you
see here what meal delivery service
works best with weight watchers
which meal delivery service is the best
where are they in canada are there meal
kit services in uk you can almost see
the sentiment by location which is why
this tool is so powerful now when i am
starting a customer persona i always
start in these arenas because i want to
see what questions a person might typed
in into google before they actually get
to me and how exactly would i answer
these areas right so that's essentially
where we're going with this now in
addition to that the last site that i'm
going to go to because like i said i'm
flying blind and i have to kind of rely
on my good friend stewart over here if
you go to spark turo
sparksure.com is the audience research
tool now we won't be able to go um into
depth with this
but if you scroll down a little bit
there's going to be a bar that's right
in the center
of this area right
now i want you to click on the drop down
where it says frequently talks about
hold on a second i'm going to
use the drop down and enter your query
frequently talks about yep you're going
to click on that drop down and you're
going to go to
um
follows social account
okay
and then you're going to type in
actually let's go to
frequently visits website and you're
going to type in www.hellofresh.com
i get i don't have frequently visits
webs oh yes we do i'm sorry
no it's okay and you're going to click
on discover now
hellofresh.com
correct
discover now
yep
now with this tool this tool actually
helps us to break down
our persona so that we know exactly
where they shop
what other places that they might visit
online
podcasts that they might listen to their
demographics this is the free version i
actually had the pay version and i
really wanted to share it with you guys
because it dives into a lot of really
cool insights but that's okay we're
working with what we have to work with
but if you scroll down a little bit
there stuart you might have a pop up
that comes up too just click out of that
um you'll see here target
you'll see target here you'll see prime
video you'll see cdc
you might see dunkin donuts and you
might see coals
uh since i don't have a free account
it's giving me the top uh
eight or visible martha stewart is the
number one
okay
doctor uh dr oz is the second one then
health.health.com southwest airlines
timac
who is a
influencer um twitch support and dunkin
donuts okay perfect
well mine's a little different but what
that tells me about these customers is
that they actually are really interested
in cooking and they are health conscious
so with these tools and this information
i can then create a sketch composite of
what my audience may look like now if
you had a paid version of this you could
actually dive into demographics and
things like that but because we don't
and we're just doing this demonstration
this is actually what i show my students
live how to segment these how to find
like their exact sentiments about
products what they love about products
what they might hate about products and
then it determines for us who we should
be going after inside of the customer
journey and what the customer
experiences at every turn what are some
factors that causes them to convert what
are the questions that they have what
problems would be solving with our
services and products so i hope that
that demonstration even though it was a
little kind of
kind of weird because i didn't have the
share feature
hopefully you were able to learn these
two very important tools to leverage in
order for you to craft the customer
journey and when you come to
any type of digital marketing program
that i am teaching these are some of the
tools that i dive into to help to craft
these areas
all right
all right stuart it's back to you
okay
um
so let's talk about the uh customer
persona and i'm going to come on camera
with you
yes
all right
so
when you go to these tools you've you've
gotten a little insight into the
customers thinking especially about how
they're approaching researching
a purchasing decision
researching a product what they're
interested in
what do you pull out of that to start
creating the the
specific personas that you want to use
in your campaigns and then how do you
use those
absolutely that's a great question so
first and foremost let's talk about what
a customer persona is
the customer persona is literally the
digital sketch composite of a person
it's almost like if you committed a
crime and they don't have your face so
they don't have the criminal they kind
of sketch out based on description
that's essentially what that is so when
you have products or services one of the
first thing that you need to do is you
need to understand
that inside of the grand scheme of your
target audience when you say what's your
target audience that's really really
broad right because that can be a number
of different people but then when you
start to use tools like this and you
start to narrow down what that
customer's needs looks like it almost
gives you the composite of that
particular customer to the t
you almost can see what they dress like
with the stores that they shop at the
type of clothes that they buy the type
of conversations that they engage in
another really cool thing that i show my
students inside of our classes is how to
see what they're actually saying online
about certain products things like that
with that you take that customer persona
and you use that customer persona for a
lot of times paid marketing so targeting
you use it to craft the content that you
need so basically you know by going to
tools like answer the public when you're
answering the questions on answer the
public that creates content you can
create video content from some of those
things or you can create static content
you can also help them down the journey
so if we know going back to that one um
text that we found if we know that
they're finding the need at the top of
the funnel then we can organize those
questions that we get from answer the
public to basically help them to
discover what their needs are
if we know that in the middle of the
funnel
and i'm keep i keep looking because i'm
looking at my other screen if they are
in the middle of the funnel and they're
researching their options then we know
how to separate ourselves from the
options that they're researching and the
option that they're looking at with us
what makes us different what makes us
better than these other areas the next
part is the actual purchasing part which
is super important because this
particular persona can act as the next
resource for the next persona that we
encounter so it is very important for us
to understand
how that particular persona interacted
to get to purchase and what are they
saying post purchase so that we can then
use that as the catalyst we call that
the zero moment of truth we can use that
as a catalyst for our next purchaser and
that's how you start to really build the
audience for the products and services
that you offer and because a lot of
these things are automated guys a lot of
this composite comes from your online
activity on places like google facebook
instagram tick tock all of these things
this is why it's important to go through
this process and understand your persona
so you're targeting the correct
content pieces and products to the right
customers at the right time
that that's
you described an iterative process kind
of a cycle where
you can start with
maybe this is the type of uh persona
that wants to buy our product based on
what we've researched about their
preferences their interests
characteristics
then we see
how their behavior takes them all the
way through to purchase and from that we
now have a population of
people who have bought the product
whose personas we can then match and
refine so
you're talking is that an accurate way
of describing it that you
create target personas and then refine
that based on
who your actual purchasers are
absolutely absolutely and then like i
said we use the purchasers as a zero
moment of truth and then that's when you
get into things like loyalty programs
and things that respond to those
particular areas so really in-depth
process
to go into for that
and then you just continuously refine it
now the really cool thing about this
process that we're speaking about is
once you have this narrowed down
when you go on these platforms the
platforms are designed to serve up our
best creatives and our best products to
the people who meet this but if you
don't know it then your content kind of
goes all over the place and this is what
creates
friction between people who are
interested in digital marketing because
they don't really understand how to do
this process succinctly with how the
platforms work
um
so
when you're looking at
tying the persona to the customer
journey
are there
touch points that you create
that say for this persona when they get
to this part of the customer journey we
expect them to behave in this way as as
distinct from somebody of a different
persona
very good question it depends on the
nature of the product now the customer
journey map that we showed you
customers pretty much react the same
right
either and and some of you can attest
even on the chat when you are looking
for a product or you see a product in
some way and you become aware of it the
first thing that you do is you want to
research the reviews on it right you got
to look at whether or not it's a good
product
then if you have enough positive
customer sentiment then what are you
going to do you're going to go ahead and
go through the purchase process
now what where things vary is is how
distracted are you
how um how are you
interacting with like notifications and
things like that so you may do something
like add this to the cart you might do
something like go into this process or
go into that process but ultimately
ultimately you are still following the
exact same journey of awareness
consideration purchase and then loyalty
so there's a baseline function of the
customer journey and then there are sort
of the variations of what a customer
might do and there's also uh if this
then this right so on the marketing end
of it if a customer does this
then this is what we should do if a
customer does this then this is what we
should do
right and that that's
really important especially when you're
looking at
things like nurturing campaigns for
somebody who's expressed interest and
now you want to take them farther down
the path
and what's their next step did they
ask for
a
direct
contact did they enter a chat with
representative did they download a white
paper or
did they you know go to
the product specification or the product
information page
and all of those things
take them in different branches of that
customer journey don't they
they do
okay
um so
when you're
when you've created i mean how many
customer personas
would one
typically create depending on the
business one you know that they're in
so one of the things is is there might
be several different segments that you
have to create
um it's not just one this is just the
process that we go to find them
but let's say for instance you are in
e-commerce e-commerce is going to behave
differently than like maybe a service
model so something that's offline
but the journey still remains the same
and the journey is still going to be i'm
aware of a problem that i have
i need to solve that problem
what business or
product is going to have me to solve
that problem and what the marketer has
to do is they have to figure out which
portion which portion or which piece of
content or which product or which
service do we need to put in front of
this person so that they know it every
term oftentimes people are looking for
products while they're driving in their
car
so it's like
you know how do we interact with these
places or how do we interact with these
folks that can't really have a call to
action so that's essentially what you do
there it is a layered process when we
definitely go over that in class
but it starts with some of these kind of
you know approaches where you're using
different tools outside of what you
currently have you may need to have
customer data that you've had from the
past and compare it to what you see now
but this is the behavior of the modern
customer journey it all starts the same
it starts with some kind of search okay
and
this impacts both
customers
with whom you are in conversation
already
that's somebody who's come to your
website come you
had some type of contact with you
and you're able to direct
communication to them
but it also
affects how you're going to find people
to get them to come into conversation
with you right so
absolutely
things like
your your external marketing and how you
reach out to the
wider audience and target and that type
of thing so
absolutely so what what they call that
is top of funnel middle of funnel and
bottom up funnel right the person that
you were describing that comes to the
website they're considered as what's
called mofo they're at the middle of
their funnel so they still have
questions they're not 100 sold on the
product or the service and they need to
reach out to get all of the information
that they need to make a decision
the top of funnel is where most
marketers or most companies spend the
most of their time why because they need
to always cycle these people through the
funnel these fun these these folks
ninety percent of the time probably i'll
say a safe sixty percent of the time
do not convert at first glance
it doesn't matter how good your content
is
they will not convert
so they need extra nurturing like you
mentioned before nurturing campaigns
sometimes they need a little bit of an
incentive to actually convert to go
ahead and try the product
it's the same way that we used to react
when we would get uh i don't know if you
guys remember but remember when they had
music and you could go and fill out the
form and get like eight cds in the mail
well that was to show you how you would
get the product that you wanted quicker
you could get the things that you wanted
and ultimately you were signed up for a
subscription some people got mad about
being signed up for a subscription but
that's how they got people in the funnel
they incentivized them so you can get
eight cds for 10 cents
fine print that was this you signed up
for you actually signed up for a
subscription service but ultimately
that's where that is so you have this
separate part of the journey and
everyone is relying differently and as i
mentioned the person that you're
describing their middle of journey
whereas the top of the funnel that's
where most of the time is spent
and you should have a sketch composite
or a customer persona for each part of
the journey in each segment of your
business
just to kind of even define that a
little further you should know the exact
age of your customer or an age range
you should know the exact
products that they tend to buy that are
adjacent to yours
so if i'm a skin care person
and i like to go to ulta
ulta carries all sorts of brands and
these types of tools teach you
if you are going to buy let's say for
instance if you're going to go buy kylie
jenner cosmetics
those personas typically also purchase
other cosmetic brands that are adjacent
like tarte cosmetics
or l'oreal or some of the more
traditional ones because now they're
branching out
into other cosmetics for options so just
because
you're offering the same thing as
someone else does not limit or exclude
you from reaching out to a specific
persona you just have to define who they
are
that's a that's a great point
that
sometimes when you're looking at
people in their buying behavior it's not
that they're going to make an either or
decision between you and a competitor
they may make a and decision
where
they may
see that
you're something that's complementary to
it or that it's like you said expands
their options so that's a great point
um exactly um i would i would also
venture to say you know and i i
i use this in class all the time how
many streaming services do you guys have
how many streaming platforms do you
engage with they all stream content but
there's a content variation you may have
netflix because it has this this and
this type of content
in my husband's case he has he likes
disney plus because that's where all the
marvel stuff is you can't find marvel
content on any platform but that doesn't
make him eliminate hulu and netflix
because he has disney plus it just means
that it's in addition to
right
that's that that's an
excellent example
um
so when we're trying to
um
drive the behavior using
personas um
because what we're looking for is
how do we attract the person of this
type persona
how do we move them through the funnel
um
are there
you talked about
some of the characteristics
how do you know which characteristics
are most important for your product or
service or brand
um so that you know
how deep to go on that persona and what
aspects are most important to you well
that's it's that's simpler than you
think you follow the customer journey
the characteristics are the same
the person is going to research
they're going to compare and eventually
they're going to make a decision
now what makes me make the decisions are
on how many times that they visited a
website guys there are software that
tells us how many times a person visits
a product how long they stay on a
product especially with email marketing
services like clavio and omnisend and
all of those
it shows you exactly what someone clicks
on whenever they're on your site how
long they visited there if they just
click on it for 10 seconds and they
leave
their interest may not be there but if i
see this customer going to the website
over a couple of days it's something
specifically that they're looking for
they're either considering this product
or trying to figure out a better way
case in point
um there is a client that i work with
and
people kept going to her website and i
was trying to figure out why are they
going to this website over a couple of
days
well i installed another piece of code
that basically told me they were going
out
of the website and going to google and
typing in her address directly so
they're leaving from facebook because
facebook kind of charts it up they're
going back to the website typing it into
google to see if her products are on
amazon
yeah that's a great example and
the other aspect
that you just reminded me of are
people who will see a facebook ad
like myself
and say
gee that's an interesting product i
wonder if this company is actually for
real and um
example of
how i modified my customer journey was i
clicked on a facebook ad once because i
happened to be a big fan of
tropical themed hawaiian type
shirts
how did i know you were going to say
that
i saw this
oh you were gonna say
hawaiian themed shirts you're in
california
and so i saw a uh a really interesting
looking shirt that i wanted to purchase
and i clicked on the facebook ad and
made the purchase
when i received it from the vendor in
china
i received
and i ordered it in my size which is a
pretty big size
they sent it in
size 4x for an infant maybe
toddler
you know i held it up like this
and
i did get a refund because i had used
paypal to pay but
the change that made to my customer
journey was when the next time i saw
a really interesting looking
shirt on a facebook ad i made sure
to go out of the ad
research the company
get
a certain degree of confidence that
it was a real company providing real
products and i looked at the reviews and
i did the things that you've described
and so i became a more educated consumer
for having been
you know ripped off
you know fooled me once shame on you
told me twice shame on me so i got
fooled once and then i learned how not
to get fooled again
in that particular
context and that's
an interesting example of
looking at you know how my persona in a
certain sense changed from the impulse
buyer who was willing to click on the ad
because
that looks really cool
to
the more
seasoned and savvy buyer who says wait a
minute
let's make sure this is a real offer so
absolutely that's that's a really good
example of um
different personas even within the same
person because the behavior changes
so
because of our technical difficulties
we're getting close to the time but what
i want to do now is open it up to um
questions from the audience if that's
okay with you
yeah go for it
okay so one more reason for them to join
one of our classes
so they can get the real deal but i hate
that we didn't have
our technology
we have just
a huge number of um of questions that
have come in
uh and i'm gonna have to
normally in in these sessions i would be
logging these um so that we could go to
them right away but i'm gonna start with
one from ruben who asked how could i
know better the visitors of my site if
they don't subscribe or register on my
site
well this is where you need to dive into
google analytics if you set up your
google analytics or you you
view your google analytics it'll tell
you an interesting story
and the way that it looks i'm not sure
if you're in e-commerce or not
but
the customer journey goes through a
process that actually is measured by
kpis so you have view content
you have add to cart you have initiate
checkout then you have like all of these
different steps and it doesn't matter
which platform you use but specifically
google analytics there's all of these
kpis that you can measure now if you
have a significant portion of people
that are viewing content
and not um going into an add to cart
then it could be that they don't
understand enough about your product but
you can't
accurately pinpoint your customer base
by just their subscription to email
because people subscribe to emails all
the time and never check them
the best way for you to understand your
customers is to look at what they're
doing on your site and you can do that
with google analytics which is free
basel
asks
if
there are people who will move directly
from awareness to purchase without going
through a consideration phase yes a very
small percentage of them in my
experience i've only seen probably about
between 15 to 20 percent of people who
go straight to a purchase phase
but even them they will be distracted
and then maybe they'll make a purchase
in a couple hours i'm very data driven i
look at a lot of data analytics and
that's where i come up with that
that describes
the first example i gave of my behavior
when i saw the thing and i said that's
cool i'm going to buy it um
that's going directly from awareness to
purchase yeah
you're probably that 20 and you never do
that again
i i i i do that in other contexts um but
uh
it's the kind of thing where sometimes
i'll do that for a
restaurant or that type of thing is it
looks good
and i saw it so let's go eat there and
then
i sometimes regret that but sometimes
it's a good thing um jayton
uh jason asks
what are some of the tools that you
mentioned when you're looking to um
get the metrics for the customer journey
and things like you know where they're
visiting how long they're spending on a
page that type of thing what are what is
the suite of tools or or is that
something that
you would recommend they they come to a
class and learn well the two that i
shared today um which i would have
dove in quite extensively because i
actually have paid subscriptions for
these so i can see a lot more metrics
than what um our good friend stewart was
trying to work with us on
definitely spark two row because i do a
lot of cross referencing with that tool
i also use a tool called spyfu and i
look at adjacent websites that i know
that has a lot of traffic
um
google analytics for sure if you have a
store some sort of online store or some
sort of e-commerce
anything that people visit you need to
have google analytics installed on there
and you need to be looking at the
metrics of their view to content ratio
to add to cart ratio or whatever action
if the if the mode of your site is to
get more people to subscribe then you
need to understand how long if someone's
looking at your at your page at whatever
content page for longer than a minute
then that's showing interest because
people have the attention span of about
six seconds
so you gotta you you gotta get you know
that portion of it and and understand
but again a lot of that comes from that
initial breakdown and people don't take
the time out to really research their
customers they just go straight into
marketing they have an overall target
audience oh i want people that's
interested in cars
yeah but what type of cars because they
could be interested in ford or kia or
lamborghini or tesla that shows a
different value and disparity of
customer and then what do those people
typically do where do they shop what
type of music do they listen to because
all of those areas are triggers for
awareness
and that's where you can present where
you want to be
yeah and and
when you say people are interested in
cars that means
so many different things to so many
different people because
you know
that could be somebody who's a real
gearhead who's interested in
taking cars and modifying them and
turning them into
street racers and that type of thing or
it could be just somebody who's
interested in different models and and
the history or elegance of particular
types of cars
what is it that interests you about a
car what is it that interests you about
this product area
and
why are you
coming to us to find out more i'm going
to put into the attendee into the chat
for the attendees
several of the
web addresses that you mentioned by the
way for your spark tour please do please
do guys
go and play with those they're really
great tools i i've used them to like i
said
i've gotten it down to a science i can
literally look at someone and have a
full sketch composite of who i'm going
after and they behave the exact way that
i anticipate them to behave every single
time
because that's what i use to draw them
and then i use the customer journey map
to actually map what their process is
process the same products and services
are different and the incentives that i
offer are going to vary but most of the
journey they're pretty predictable on
that wise
we have a couple of related questions
about
um
what's the most valuable question to
answer when you're trying to define your
customer persona and what are the
metrics you use
but um
i mean that's
going to be
one i guess
if i predict your answer
the most valuable question is probably
not a good thing to ask it's it's a set
of valuable questions right um
well
yes and no it that's a really powerful
question that you asked i'm not sure
what your name is it's a powerful
question that you ask and one of the
things is is all of this boils down to
revenue let's just keep it all the way
real
one of the things is going to boil down
to revenue and what the propensity of
that person's purchasing power is
for example
a person who
buys the same types of groceries
at the same type of store so whether it
be like a publix or whatever your local
store is
then that person has already been mapped
out inside of a customer lifetime value
this means that their propensity to
spend over time
and once they get into that funnel this
determines how much money you're going
to spend to acquire them
so this would be in discounts this would
be in meeting them in all of those
phases of the customer journey to ensure
that this person becomes a customer
so essentially the main foundational
question is what is your customer's
lifetime value what value are they to
your business
to your services or products that you
offer
then you ask the subset of questions of
who are they where are they what music
they listen to what products do they
typically buy where do they find those
products all of those different areas
okay we're at
about at times so i want to
move to the wrap up but there's a lot of
questions if there are particular
questions that you would like me to pass
on to bernadette
you have uh you all have my email
address
stuart.creek simplylearn.net that came
to you in the
invitation email you got for the webinar
so
um
i'm going to
get to part of our presentation that
talks about something that's come up as
one of the questions
that people have asked so let me
bring back up our
presentation
and a number of people have asked
in the q a
about how to get
started or how to learn more about
digital marketing what programs we offer
so i'm going to to make a
pitch for two of the programs that we
offer one is digital marketing associate
which is a program designed
for people who are kind of starting out
in digital marketing
want to get into the field
and it
gives you the basic foundations for some
of the fundamental skills seo content
marketing
how to do pay-per-click advertising
some social media strategy which is
bernadette's most favorite thing and
other things of that nature including
digital analytics and understanding how
to use tools to look at
customer behavior and the customer
journey um
that's one of our programs the other is
the digital marketing specialist program
digital marketing specialist program
goes into much more depth
and gives you access to a number of
electives that let you go into
specific digital marketing
topics and skills
um
so both of these are great programs that
simply learn offers
um
and
we're offering to you for being on this
webinar today for having attended a
discount of 15 off of
these programs so what i'm going to put
into the chat right now
are the um
links
to both of these programs you can take a
look and compare them see what makes
sense for you if you're interested in
doing something of this type
and
so i
try to find the chat
here we go
and so you have those links in the chat
right now to take a look at those
courses
taught by
great instructors like bernadette
which is very very pleased that she was
able to be here today and i'm going to
ask a poll question
just to get a feel from the audience
about
what are the things that you're
interested in learning adding to your
toolkit for digital marketing
i'll give you about
30 seconds or so to answer this pick one
two three all of them
whichever
are most important to you and also when
do you want to get started i mean if
you're if you're looking to add these
skills
is this something that you're planning
to do
soon or is this something that you
think will be
somewhere in the distant future so
we always say that if it's something
that's going to improve your career
improve your life and improve your
salary it's probably worth doing sooner
than later
and just five more seconds
watch the numbers roll in
so content marketing happens to be the
one
of the skills that has the largest
response along with analytics
followed by seo and then uh things like
website conversion
social media
and a third of our audience says that
they'd like to start learning these
skills right away so you can
look at the programs i mentioned that
i've given you links to you can look at
other
offerings on the simply learn site
we have some programs that are even
affiliated with
university partners
so
please do take a look at those and
with that i'm going to
thank bernadette for being here today
and i will also put into the chat
per linkedin information
so you can get to this url without
having to copy it off the screen
by the way for our streaming audience
today if you
do go to ask us at simplylearn.net
and do tell them that you were on this
session today and that
you would like to take advantage of the
discount we can offer that to you
for being here today
so
with that
thank you very much bernadette for being
here
i apologize it was my pleasure
i apologize for the the technical issues
from this platform
and
i'm hoping that we'll be on a different
platform
in the near future but in the meantime
thank you for your patience
i'm going to talk to the audience about
our next webinar which is coming up a
week from today is with
nick kolikovsky who is
a senior editor at dice which is the
premier technical hiring
platform and technical uh career
information platform
uh in the united states and
he's going to talk about what the elite
companies and the
meta amazon
apple
netflix and google range
are looking for in their tech hires so
he'll he'll be able to share his
insights into the industry
this is a
good
good
overview of the trends that are coming
up and and what he sees coming in in the
future especially as we're going into a
period of economic uncertainty so this
is a really good webinar we invite you
to join that i'm going to put the link
to that into our chat
and
as i do that
i want to thank everybody for being here
invite you to
follow us on our
social channels
and we're at simply learn on facebook
and twitter or simply learn on
linkedin
and i want to thank
everyone for being here and you have
that link to the um
next week's webinar in the chat here
so again thank you bernadette
thank you for your patience especially
no worries we'll get them next time
stuart
appreciate it
and uh again
apologies to everybody for the technical
difficulties thank you for sticking with
us uh through this webinar
and uh as i said i hope we can welcome
you into the simply learn learning
community and we look forward to seeing
you
in our webinars and on our courses in
the future so
that concludes
today's webinar
you